good evening clean everybody my name's
Andy Crump welcome to tonight's meeting
our strategies
Katsura counting committee be the
purpose of tonight's meeting is to
decide the planning merits of the
applications before us before we start
the meeting can I ask members the public
to make sure their phones are either on
silent or switched off obviously there's
nothing worse than somebody speak and
then there being a lot interrupted by
the sounds of the great escape or Scooby
Doo or or whatever and also ask you not
to interrupt the speakers however
tempting that may be because we do know
that people who have registered are the
only people allowed to speak tonight so
if necessary we look to me if it becomes
too bad too many interruptions we can
clear the hall so just like to introduce
the top table make sure - legal services
Dale Barker planning manager Alex
cosmetic Senior Planner Ben Sam Walsh
County Council highways
Thank You Sara we'll come back to Daniel
to explain his role in tonight's
committee thank you
I'm the planning manager for tonight's
committee and my role is to provide
impartial advice to clarify any planning
issues that arise and to assist members
decision taking I'm bound by the Royal
Town Planning Institute code of
Professional Conduct and planning
committee members are not bound by any
advice from officers or by their
recommendations Thank You chair officers
chair we've got apologies from
councillor Fleming he can't sir Jennings
is substituting for and councillor
junior who can't sir Adam is
substituting for thank you very much
thank you for substituting happy and
have an enjoyable time I'm sure you will
right next item on the agenda
disclosures of interest please catch the
mouse thanks mr. chairman on item eight
I do know the weather speakers and
Eterna just a bit declare my interest
mr. chairman thank you
Willie where you used to be part of the
committee oh yes no yes yes in fact okay
Casca was my yeah i'll declare an
interest on the same application 19 / 0
1 1 1 6 ful and I've been in quite
extensive conversations with the
applicant so I will be standing down on
that one and letting catch the Mills
who's calmly going to chair that item
thank you we've got two more I forgot to
pay can I forget you two gentlemen
okay sir bonds it's a moon beer I have a
parish meeting hey [ __ ] get there
later on it starts to change LD yeah I
shall be coming up for committee chair
for item 5 it's that the one where your
wooden as a ward member right so if I
miss anybody else no right thank you
very much
next done the minutes we need to confirm
the mix all the meetings held on the
22nd of May and the 26th of June more
happy that yet proposed in a second yep
why's it favor yep agreed thank you very
much moving swiftly on and the next item
on agenda it's application number 15/0
three separate five early London West of
Stratford south of lobster Road and the
north of Evesham Road struck furred from
incb 37 deep breath now removal of
condition thirty-one on-site renewable
sources and variation of condition 33
lament on France for submission of code
of sustainable homes final certificate
condition 37 hard and soft landscape in
condition 54 garden area noise effect on
planet emission own 9 /o t1 not sick
thank you Javon the application site is
outlined in red on the plan outline
planning permission was granted to the
PIO in 2012 for the erection of up to
800 dwellings mixed-use local centre and
highways infrastructure the application
the four members this evening is a
section 73 application relating to this
granted outline consent it seeks very or
remove a number of conditions and was
given a resolution to grant by planning
committee on the 5th of April 2017 the
same section 73 application is for for
members again this evening as the
applicant proposes the addition of a new
condition which sets parameters for open
market housing mix to which the
remaining phase 2 reserved matters would
be governed by in order to give some
context this plan shows the various
phases Planning Committee has resolved
to approve reserved matters for 200
dwellings in the Northern Development
area phase 1 which I inserted
with my mouse here and prefer the 197
dwellings here in the southern
development area phase 1 phase 2 which
covers the remaining 403 dwellings in
this location here local center in blue
and primary school in purple will be
submitted later this year the new
housing mixed condition would set
parameters for open market housing mix
on phase 2 only members should note that
there is no condition on the existing
outlined consent which relates to
housing mix as established in the
committee report the new housing mixed
condition would be a clear benefit to
the authority in that it would ensure a
reasonable housing mix is proposed in
the forthcoming reserved matters
application where at president with no
housing its condition there is no
mechanism by which to control open
market housing mix through reserved
matters chairman the recommendation is
to grant the application in line with
committees previous resolution but with
the attachment of the new open market
housing mix condition thank you thank
you sir our first speaker please which
is councillor Toby Lee from
stratford-upon-avon town capsule either
one is fine thank you no middle council
knee and that's right you've got three
minutes
would you like a warning with about 30
seconds to go right thank you far away
ready please
very much letting you speak tonight and
I wasn't expecting to be perfumes to be
speaking at least I think you just have
your microphone slightly closer to
burden sorry very expecting to be
speaking at this and we met with the
developer and fairly recently actually
decent meeting as far as I could tell
however when I looked into the actual
history of the application as normally
do when when looking at these items I
was aghast to be perfectly honest that
the plumbing condition on renewable
energy in which condition 31 is being
removed I couldn't really understand the
decision behind that so I've read a
little further I do actually work in the
renewables and energy industry on much
larger scale of schemes so it's
something very close to my heart and on
that same line of thought I was very
pleased actually two weeks ago the
Stratford District Council were debating
the climate emergency and looking to put
that in put a resolution in place and
put a look into an action in place so
for me this contradicts that actively
removing a condition which is aiming to
reduce climate change impacts on
accounts all that has just resolved to
declare the climate change emergency
it's a bit of a conflict to me I think
so also sets a dangerous precedent for
moving forwards that in order to use to
address the climate emergency it's not
just a case of talking about it you need
to walk the walk as well and for me
removed actively removing a condition
which helps is very odd to me looking
for the legislation there is no legal
reason why it should be removed
primary legislation that was talking the
report issued by the developer which
cites the deregulation act as removing
this ability for councils to set policy
in this area councils clearly can you
have you have got Court Justice III
which promotes decentralized energy an
on-site generation so for me I find this
a very odd decision and I wish you to
consider this particularly in light of
the climate emergency that has been
declared and will also be debated at the
Town Council tomorrow for him thank you
cancelling any questions
Hey before you go any questions for Ken
slowly I think it was very clear what
you you your point was so then what we
always like to give fair catches the
opportunities to ask questions right
thank you very much you're free to go
right our next speaker please which is
mr. Nick Rawlings
got three minutes again miss Rawlings
and again if you want a warning we're
about 30 seconds I'll be fine okay thank
you good evening unusual to be a
planning committee on a Monday evening
but that's pretty good quite reasonably
asked well why are we looking to
introduce conditional control over the
open market mix of our homes when there
currently is none
the simple answer is that as your
officers just said there's gonna be four
hundred and three homes including all
the affordable units on phase two and
Bloor need a certainty over the type and
mix of houses then we're going to be
permitted to build over what will be the
next 1012 years of construction activity
and that needs to be set against the
significant amount of front-loaded in
expenditure that this development the
particulars infrastructure is going to
incur in delivering you know what it's a
key strategic site for the town but also
for the whole district I mean you only
have to look at the outline conditions
in the section section 106 agreement to
get a feel for this and how much money
is going to be spent in the areas of the
scheme now that's not a sort of plea for
sympathy it's a reality within two years
of commencement of development the
entirety of the southwest relief Road
through the site and the Anne Hathaway's
cottage access roundabout and the
crossings needs to be not only in place
but opened but that's going to be about
20 million pounds worth of expenditure
within the first 24 months with
proportionally very very little revenue
coming back so what we need we need to
know that the houses that we're going to
be building on the site has that
certainty we need that mix security so
it's quite unusual but I believe it's
got firm benefits for the district
council as well and and the mix itself
it's been well informed with very
conscious of CS 19 were very conscious
of Neighborhood Development planning
we're very conscious about the evidence
base that underpins all of that
evidence but we also are aware of other
schemes that have been approved and the
mix particularly the strategic sites but
the one point I really want to get
across and I trust that members will
have picked this up
is the cap on the unit sizes that we're
proposing and this is a really important
point because this isn't just about
following one bed to bed three bed for
their percentage apportionment this is
about the size of units that were going
to be building which is why we've made
it clear that 30 seconds sorry
most of our units will be less than
1,600 square foot if they're for bed
only seven and a half percent of the
units will be larger so the vast
majority will be small for bed
accommodation where it's war beds lots
of threes lots of twos and that improves
accessibility and affordability to the
market I'm quite happy to address the
fabric first approach for anybody's got
any questions in respect to the 10%
energy it's something that's come out
quite late mr. Oren's thank you very
much so any questions mr. Oren's
cascavel
presumably you have requested that call
condition 31 is removed that hasn't been
introduced by the officers what's the
application well it was introduced some
time ago this is that was a condition
that was requested and approved subject
to back in I believe is April 2017 at
the Planning Committee so the current
proposal that we have put forward is
just to introduce a new condition we
haven't changed anything from what went
before sorry I'm understanding but it
actually says this application is seeks
to remove stroke very large conditions
on the outline consent put appoint one
removal condition 31 on-site renewable
sources that's correct that the
that there's a resolutions probably when
the officers will be able to answer it
into the chronology but there was a
resolution from planning committee back
in early 2017 to remove or amend for
conditions upon the outlined consent and
that's been a resolution subject to 106
variation ever since what we're doing or
what we have applied for most recently
and what is the as I understand it the
the main item of this proposal is to add
a condition on to the section 73
permission which it carries the
resolution to grant from two years ago
appreciate that's my take on it us not
as an officer so could you satisfy us
given that we have as a council adopted
the climate change crisis proposal that
was put forward and for my portfolio
holder did actually speak of that
concept meeting and say that we have to
accept that is a sea change and where we
go forward
what renewable features will you be
introducing to the eight hundred houses
it total yeah which will make a
significant enhancement to either energy
saving or set of panels on the roofs or
whatever yeah that's a good question the
whole approach that we have law is about
fabric first so you design in the energy
efficiency in the first place and if you
can do that you can do that successfully
you make a dramatic reduction on the
call on energy and demand in the first
place so our approach really is about
reducing that demand rather than
to make up for it we fit fabric first as
a build approach on all of our homes
it's it's governed by Building
Regulations and that includes high
efficiency wall roof floor insulation a
rated low carbon boilers and heating
controls organ for double glazing one
hundred percent low energy bulbs right
the way through that's just the houses
and then there's also the site as well
where we could we're governed by say
site waste minimisation plans
construction and traffic management
plants all designed to reduce energy so
it's something we build in upfront so
there's no need to retrofit buy and
maintained by the new homeowners and
that's something that we're very driven
by and it's it's one of the key things
that with regards to our new homeowners
they they really are looking for now you
know they that they want
energy-efficient homes they don't want
to be paying out a lot of bills and it's
one of the key reasons why I believe
that the you know we know hbf five star
builder with 94% customer satisfaction
it's what homeowners are looking for
it's about reducing that requirement in
the very first place thank you very much
I'll notice on the plumb there that
there are no green spaces within the
dwelling areas there's quite a lot of
houses in that space the green areas are
on the outside oddly use yeah I I think
it's I suppose it's one of the pros and
cons of putting an illustrative layout
upon the board that's really just to
show the overall
Mainland use arrangements as part of the
urban extension I can assure you and you
can see it in the phase when it proved
was it already in mate reserve matter
and what will come through in September
with our phase two that there's a lot of
amenity open space as well as all the
details for the UM for the play areas
within the site and the way that the the
public open space will be actually
detailed out it looks very brown and
green when you look at it on a screen
like that but the reality are be quite
different
okay curtain character response on
renewables yes one could design a
property to be to minimize usage but
actually the whole drive is to minimize
use of carbon fuels and you just put the
idea that dhabi energy efficient boilers
technology because I think there is a
real concern given the positions
councils adopted about renewable as much
as mitigating and avoiding heat loss
yeah I think that would take us into a
whole new consideration once you get
into ground source heat pumps and
district heating you you've got to have
an awful lot of other infrastructure in
place for that but just on the boilers I
mean the boilers themselves they include
the flue gas heat recovery so if a
technology has moved on and it's what
building regs are taking us towards
that's what we we embrace it's it's
something that for Bloor in particular
we're very keen on we can make more
savings up front through a fabric first
designed approach which is why building
regs actually I know the driver for this
then if we had to go back and try and
find
percent renewable energy recovery him
somewhere else it's best to make that
saving through what you build and that's
our approach okay I think you've
answered our question fully and you've
cost me some straw beans we've got any
visual plans what these houses are going
to look like we've got it we've got a
basic plan but what are they where these
homes is going to actually look like
certainly is there's there's there's
full elevation or floor plan materials
street scene 3d drawings for all of the
draw all of the houses that have been
approved in phase one of law which is
the area in the top right and also for
the phase one reserved matters of bovis
homes which is the southern development
area there so they've all been submitted
and when we submit our phase two scheme
in September it will come with the full
elevational and aesthetic drawings that
you'll be able to see them okay
thank you yep thanks very much any
further questions again concerns a serif
and we'll we'll talk about that and
offices and points of clarification as
well right mr. Owens I think you're free
to go thank you and we've got to ward
members now I believe Texas cleave and
Curtis
no we haven't got to order numbers so
you know better right we'll move on to
points of clarification for the offices
I guess the kettle do you everyone do
you want to clarify that with the
officers your point this renewable
energy issue why are we proposing given
our current position as of last Monday a
week ago today where we have identified
this council supports the concept of
climate change emergency there are two
aspects to that one of which is
minimizing energy usage and that is
minimizing carbon usage and by removing
this clause
cause all condition 31 which is a
requirement on renewables not on energy
savings we're actually running contrary
to the policy adopted last Monday
although obviously we have to take very
seriously the direction of travel that
the council as a whole is going in on
the subject of climate change I think
it's key to note that that isn't a
policy or a planning policy by which
introduces certain standards which we
have to ensure applications comply with
so the reason 431 being removed which
was put forward and followed by the
previous planning committee in April
2017 is explained on page 24 and 25 of
your committee agenda although I
appreciate the climate change emergency
which has been announced in policy terms
no changes to legislation or policy to
mean that a different assessment should
be carried out or a different conclusion
reached so if the simple answer is for
the reason outlined in your committee
agenda is why the recommendation is to
remove conditions that are too on
something further on that really because
we're looking at an aspect that was
cleared through committee previously but
this is now this is now arising with an
additional variation are the aspects of
that were originally approved by
committee up for debate
again by this committee now I think it's
fair to say that because we've never
formally determined the application it
can be reopened by Planning Committee I
think the important thing to notice that
we need to be satisfied that something
has changed to justify a change in
decision by the council so if members
are say for example example minded to
insist that condition 31 remains the
needs to be planning reason as to what
has changed in that two years to lead us
to a different conclusion than we were
at in April 2017 that's a turtle I gave
her the opportunity to read that page 25
so thank you guys for that it's not in
the cordon of the governments direction
of travel well
this council has changed its direction
of travel since 2017 this council has
now identified as an overarching policy
for this council which after all
underpins everything we should be doing
that we have a climate change in
emergency and for those who are here
and listen to the we got this feedback
going again and those who are here would
have heard energy generation is as
fundamental as energy saving this is nor
face small estate this is probably one
of the top 10 estate this is part of our
core strategy 800 out of fourteen
thousand six hundred is a significant
proportion under the remaining balance
of 7,000 homes to be delivered in the
next 15 years this is more than 10% of
that I've got a real problem given what
this council has adopted and you may say
it's not planning policy it is the
problem
[Music]
we had the same problem while answering
the council mayor and council Pemberton
clearly said if we adopt this policy we
have to consider this as a game we have
considered as a game changer and yet
what you're saying is is contrary to
planning policy I think we we need to
reconsider that so basically is there a
way that we can really incorporate as a
condition closed 31 along side of the
housing mix and under summer housing mix
haven't got a problem with that it's not
none of the core strategy but it wasn't
there in the first place so I'm
completely comfortable with the
principle of what this application is
for don't is this policy that this
amendment about planning mix bringing in
a relaxation of where this council
currently stands which is in accordance
with this district councils direction
trouble so can you help me how can we
get to expect I think in answer to your
question we can retain condition 31 if
members consider the announcement the
climate change crisis a policy basis for
doing seven of planning basis for doing
so what I would say is it's kind of a
word of caution it's a couple of things
firstly is I think if we are insisting
on renewable sources through condition
31 there's a risk that because of
everything comes down to cost there's a
chance that we're undermining any sort
of fabric first objective so actually
the buildings will be built less energy
efficient because they've got the
renewables and we end up on the same
so that's the first thing the second
thing is for the legal basis set out on
page 25 of your agenda I've identified
why a condition to this effect isn't
necessary essentially because it's
covered by Building Control so officers
recommendation to members has to be that
it doesn't meet the condition tests in
as much as it's not necessary to have
that as a condition on the permission
but we will obviously leave it to
members to determine his planning
committee but I did just want to flag
those two points that I think Dale
wanted to add something as well
they're gone yes Thank You Alice I think
the first point is that council care
please absolutely right and if it is the
mood of members to insist that this
condition remains on you have that
ability to leave the condition on the
permission absolutely you're right
there's a reason why we're recommending
that you don't in the full knowledge of
the decision that you took that council
only just a few days ago I think the
first one is that we work in partnership
with the major developers we work in
partnership with law and we spend a lot
of time negotiating things with them
we've been working on this scheme since
Alice 2015 for years we've been working
on this we're expecting to issue the
decision notice in the next seven days
and now members are considering going
back and renegotiating that's not
helping us to negotiate in good faith
with law in the future to get the best
development for Stratford they're
proceeding down one one direction with
one set of expectations and suddenly at
the last minute we are suggesting
changing the basis of the permission
that's the first point the second point
is I don't often do this but but I'd
like to quote Eric Pickles 26th of March
2015 Eric Pickles was Secretary of State
for Communities and Local Government and
he said local planning authorities must
no longer grant planning permission for
housing developments that require
specific levels of the code for
sustainable homes and technical housing
standards relating to the construction
internal layout or performance of new
dwellings that was all handed over to
Building Control at that time now yes
it's quite right that you can we should
introduce policies that require certain
standards but as things stand at the
moment we're operating on the basis of
that advice from councillor pickles that
hasn't been superseded and our
recommendation is made after
considerable thought members and our
recommendation stands thank you all
right thank you for that down I was very
clear I'm gonna start you changing the
subject 15 so I'm correct there's one
footnotes it says the combination of for
bed small and large dwelling shall be no
more than 30
point five percent clear at the market
mix so just making sure okay does that
mean 62 and a half percent minimum three
bed and less right any other questions
no so I just wanted to clarify for you
counselor and to Sarah in terms of the
design of dwellings at this stage
because we're looking at adding a new
house Mitch conditioned onto the outline
the design of dwellings isn't the four
members but committee did consider the
design for the two areas here and here
we've got resolution to grant and
subsequently if triggers Planning
Committee for sort of elevations and
street scene elevations and designs the
dwellings will be provided for the
forthcoming reserve matters Carol
mr. Barker I understand that you've been
working very hard on this and this is a
major scheme I've already identified
it's a very nice game the District
Council and not surprisingly you have
all been putting vast amounts of hours
in to get this right what mr. pickels
said in 2015 I don't care to know this
we're in a very very different position
but to your principal point about
negotiation is development of course
it's important for you to work for
developers to get the best outcome for
the for the district
we have the protection as you've also
said a building control to ensure that
insulation standards meet the best
practice that we can achieve so that
isn't something that we can give away
that's part of any deal because building
control zone are the same as it's done
it weren't part of building control so I
can't see how that's a negotiable issue
is there a I mean if we were to
reinstate or the conditions to stand or
in an amended form does that not give
you the ability to continue to negotiate
with the developer because they've got
to submit to another application in
October I believe the reserved matters
application but that is not going to
delay that at any stage why can't we
look at this again and say what
opportunities are there for renewable
regeneration whether it be ground source
heat pumps whether it be one of it is
tiles whether it be one in us look at
almost every time I know we're looking
at application later on or some looking
at application in my ward and it on
where the solar panels on the roof why
can't we put in a condition we know
we're safe with the insulation levels
because that can't cover Building
Control why can't we put a condition
that says do your best we need to do
better
good confirmation just to clarify on mr.
pickles the statement the policy was
actually a government policy and it was
withdrawn on the 27th of March 2015 that
was the sustainable homes code just to
confirm our chair and what just one
further point I don't believe we've
actually with condition 31 the type of
conditions 31 we've actually applied
that condition since that ministerial
statement that's correct yeah we've
relaxed it on a number of applications
since then because the minister will
take statement took away the legitimacy
for the condition in order to answer
councilor kettles question directly the
policy cs3 in your call strategy all new
developments in other areas will be
encouraged to incorporate infrastructure
for district heating don't think I'm
reading the wrong bit bear with me page
13 I think
chairman sorry I probably best if I
don't actually read the policy but the
you'll put your policy cs3 talks about
making provision for renewable energy
and low carbon generation within the
district and of course removing the
policy removing the condition doesn't
prevent us from negotiating all of that
with the developer but negotiating it in
good faith bearing in mind that members
resolved to vary this condition to
remove this condition in April 2017 two
years ago so the developer has been
going forwards in one direction for two
years which is now going to have to
change freight chair is the only answer
I can give thank you in the notes
references the fact that no policy
requirement was in the then emerging
core strategy that was in the notes that
for the for the planning planning report
that went through committee what date
did the core strategy actually get
solidified behind that and there's a
couple of things I mean that is the
briefing note which was submitted on
behalf of Bloor where they've put no
policy requirement in the ven call
strategy obviously we have got relevant
policies relating to energy conservation
but none of them specifically say we
have to produce ten per sentence it was
adopted in July 2007 to 16 July 2016 it
was adopted so prior to this application
going for planning committee
but host Eric Pickles statement in 2015
right cut the things before we move on
we've got quite a bit on the agenda
tonight so can't we make sure that we
have questions that are just questions
rather than the statement then a
question
otherwise we'll be here all night
another question for Alice it was
mentioned that Building Control would
have some control basically of the
standards the properties
mr. almond spoke about which we're going
to be high-spec what the control have
control over Lowe's and if we insist
having sustainable energy such as the
tiles such as the heat that cancer
kettle was mentioned is there a risk
that by having glows that they could
build the houses to a lower standard
still within the control are still
within the control of all standards at
the burn and control that would negate
any savings yes so in answer to your
first question with regards to boilers
yes Building Control would have a say
over that and secondly my I do think
that that is a risk that if we insist on
the provision of renewables because of
the cost you know in ansible it does
come down to that there is a risk that
the buildings won't be built to the same
energy efficient standards because they
don't need to because they're producing
renewable energy whereas the idea of
fabric verse is to make the buildings as
sustainable in the first place as
possible so you don't have to offset
that additional energy generation
it's just saved through occupation of a
building which is more energy
efficient supplemental planning document
queue adopted by this council in
February 20 1982 district heating
networks does this relaxation of
condition 31 comply with the spirit of
what was intended in SPD to the council
has identified a couple of district
heating priority areas long being a
canal Porter mom being on last an
airfield because of the outline
permission being in place on shatori no
feasibility work has been undertaken at
this site in terms of whether district
heating is a feasible and viable option
members could ultimately insist that it
is looked into in terms of whether
district heating is feasible but you're
then looking at delaying the permission
by Sur for two years which you obviously
have a huge knock-on impact on our
five-year supply with the ultimate aim
that it may just be found to be not
feasible and viable in which case we're
in exactly the same position but
potentially lacking our five-year supply
also we have to consider the fact that
the developer does have the original
outline consent is a fallback option so
it's likely that they wouldn't go down
the route of establishing whether
district heating were feasible or viable
they would look to implement the
original outline condition commission
that's more quite clear I think shall we
move on to the debate who wants to start
on this one because the fielding and
then counts the Barnes
as I was the only person that abstained
on the vote on Monday week
John keep microphone a bit closer places
certainly I don't want it to whistle at
you I quite happy to go along with the
counts the officers decision that we go
ahead and removing section 31 and
basically what's in the report I'm quite
happy to accept so I propose that we
accepted castor bonds
I never said similar mind my concern on
for climate change but I do feel that
before this meeting or after this
meeting we need to get together and know
where we're going because otherwise
we're going to have a problem
I've just had windows with gas in them
pudding all right a technical thing
lovely lovely and warm in the winter
there are lot of things that we could
bring up and I think it's something that
needs addressing and I'm quite happy to
second this recommendation
i abstain not on the grounds that i
agree that there is a problem but I
didn't agree that he was an emergency so
I would make my with you on that point I
think that yes the previous committee
did recommend the resolve to actually my
condition yeah okay any other points it
any cool cousin kettle III do have real
problem with this dropping of clothes 31
it is a no-brainer that we should be
looking at every opportunity we docked
to the core strategy which talked about
renewable energy we've adopted
whatever I said the SPD cute I think it
was which was about looking up ways of
minimizing the use of carbon filled not
between not putting energy-efficient
carbon heating systems in but looking at
alternative heating systems in and
whilst I don't want to make officers
life more difficult I think the fact
that we have we are sitting here today
despite where we are globally and in
this council and even the one absentee
has now I explained he's not he's not
disagreeing with the issue of climate
change problems just familiar with the
classification of crisis I think it is
incumbent on all of us as councilor
Pemberton clearly said in this room last
week that we have to start thinking
outside the box and therefore
we have to accept the proposal put
forward subject to an amendment relating
to clause 31 so that every effort is
made before the reserve application is
heard in October
the renewable energy is brought back
onto the table of this application
because I do not believe it is
acceptable in this day and age to this
constable is seen dropping conditions
which require renewable energy I'm sorry
you men started four years ago but we're
in a very very different place four
years ago and this council needs to sit
up and be aware of where we are today
so if we can define a way of readjust
assessing of clause 31 as a revised
condition that I'm very happy to accept
that I cannot vote toward something
which is just removing it that's the
mouse thanks for chairman horn here the
keeping the condition on is this going
to push the price of houses up so
therefore first-time buyers are going to
have a bigger problem than ever just be
the case do you think I'd like to
clarify again just to make sure if we go
down the road of maintaining the
condition in some form for condition 31
the original condition will be a watered
down version that catch the kettle was
suggesting am i right in saying that the
applicants could go back to the original
permission which hasn't got the section
31 conditioning no because although
there's a resolution to grant from
committee to remove condition 31 because
the decision notice was never formally
issued because it's subject to the legal
agreement which having been complete yet
they don't have an option to implement a
permission without condition 31
everybody else knows that but I didn't
bother just making sure
hence they failed him I understand where
councillor kettles coming from but the
the scheme it's a bit unfair to suddenly
produce something in the middle of a
scheme that's off or on underway the for
future developments I think we've got to
take a view with regards to that
decision but in this case I think we've
got to allow common sense unless of
course there is something that you as
chairman can agree with the officer that
can be incorporated in our resolution
sorry dunya Michael the actual make sure
we got this right again I've got another
thing I should have raised perhaps in a
questions myself wishing to rise it so
bear with me please are we by agreeing
to the condition for section 31 the
condition 31 potentially risking
sustainable energy efficiencies in the
boat process by agreeing to renewable
energy so they've still got they could
be built to a lower standard to make a
cost-saving to pay for the energy
efficiency renewable that's correct and
that was in support of the original
section sympathy application which
proposed the removal of condition 31 the
applicant submitted a briefing note from
white peak planning it's referred to on
page 25 and one of the reasons they put
forward for justifying the removal as
well as the legislature selective
contacts was the you'll see on the one
two three four fifth power down however
it is argued that should condition 31
remain the developers would be required
to incorporate renewable energy
technologies potentially to the
detriment of building fabric efficiency
which is more favorable option so yes I
do believe that is a risk but we don't
know that that will culminate they
certainly agree just for is there any
numerical data towards what type of
variation would have been the quality of
energy efficiency so what sort of levels
of energy efficiency we might have to go
from what the other because at the
moment it seems quite a lot of
suggesting that it would
but we don't know because we're not
actually looking at figures of course no
unfortunately don't have any more
information for that the reason being
that that for us the justification is
the legislations changed so we don't
need any specific figures to justify it
as offices so comment but they could
reduce the energy efficiency we know
there is a minimum standard which is set
by Building Control which in fact isn't
a minimum it's quite a high standard
buildings now have to meet significantly
higher levels of energy efficiency than
was the case three four five years ago
by saying that the might be a trade-off
there is a de minimis trade-off because
they can't go below building standards
but we cannot quantify you cannot
quantify whether we're talking about a
one or two percentage loss in energy
efficiency or a 90 percent loss in the
new energy efficiency it is our
hypothesis put forward yes it's going to
be less economic for these properties if
they have some sort of renewable energy
scheme very having said that it might be
more efficient we might have cheaper
electricity being generated which might
in the running cost these houses his
cheaper Brazil time to buy carbon fuels
and actually would be a saving and make
these houses more more valuable rather
than less about counts the other point
I say we my problem is at the moment
we've got a lot of imponderables that we
don't know that they might like might
build the houses to a lower standard to
compensate for pain additional life or
renewable sources such as the the heat
source ground and the solar panel was
that sound shocking obviously is there's
a capsule we need to set a standard we
need to set an example benomar we set
the garment emergency last week I think
the problem with condition 31 is we are
tied to a fisherman and 110 percent of
predicted carbon dioxide emissions from
the total energy requirements perhaps I
would be happier if we had condition 31
with the slight amendment where the
development hereby committee shall not
be commenced on to the scheme for the
provision of energy from on-site
renewable sources has been submitted to
and approved in Lorton
yes sorry almost finished then yes so
the developer to submit a scheme for the
provision of energy from one site
renewable sources to be approved to be
submitted to and approved in writing by
the local employment authority so we're
not sticking to the 10% of the protected
carbon emissions because we've not got
even if anything to quantify to say
those 10% emissions could potentially
offset reduction in in building
standards so I'm seeking as a way
forward as a compromise that we've come
forward with the scheme and then the
offices will look at the scheme and
projects have been approved
I'll have it support that question and
again it's the fight to earn me are you
yeah I think we could have been we've
got to be quite pragmatic about this and
I think there might be some some delay
but obviously autopsy it's in the
developer's interest to try and get
these built as quickly as possible
especially beings you've got quite
offset costs initially and also it's an
our interest as part of a five-year
housing on supplier to make sure that
needs a built out as well so I think
this is a way forward so if you're happy
to
sorry about this so just to sum up we've
had the proposal and the second it
seconded broadcast the bonds to go with
the officers recommendation with the
additional condition 31 being reinstated
as I read out earlier bigger as amended
with the submission of a scheme for the
provision of energy from on-site
renewables to be approved to be
submitted and to be approved in writing
by the local planning authority sorry
just a point of clarification this is
just relating to Phase two fine
just wanted to check that that was clear
what they were voting on are we okay
with that no we are happy yes should we
go to the vote all those in favor all
right thank you very much committee
resolves to grant subject to hold on
sorry about this Hagen city
adding to the amendments are to subject
to the moment they arrived in grant
subject to section 106 agreement etc
thank you for that
could we just have a just avert
right thank you very much I will now
move on to our next item on the agenda
[Music]
it's application di SC summers like
d.i.s.c.o wasn't it that one
are we still awake over that good I'm
glad to see somebody still away right /
0 0 1 2 3 / 19 ready to a land adjacent
to the a 402 3 country highway east of
Ravens Bank and when the eights greens
Redditch and presenting offices Alice
Alice Thank You chairman the application
site which is noted by the black dot in
the center of the plan is located on the
edge of the built-up area of red edge
the site as outlined in red is allocated
for employment development under
policies red one and red two of the core
strategy planning permission has been
granted on the site for 32 hectares of
employment land for business and
industrial uses the plan on screen shows
the approved parameters plan the grant
of Planning Commission was subject to a
legal agreement and forty-three
conditions two of which are presented to
members this evening condition 19
requires the submission and approval of
a HDV routing strategy to prevent HCV
traffic routing through mapable green
and steadily the latter of which is a
designated air quality management area
and condition 20 which requires the
submission and approval of hahdve
surveys to demonstrate the
implementation and operation of the HCV
routing strategy part of this condition
requires the developer to submit the
methodology for undertaking the HCV
surveys for approval the discharge of
condition application before members
seeks the approval of the HDB routing
strategy against condition 19 and the
part approval of hahdve surveys innocent
as condition 20 requires the approval of
the methodology for undertaking the HTV
surveys so just to help members to get
their bearings this is the application
science up here so this is sort of two
triangles which I showed you on a slide
a couple moments ago coming down to math
or a green and the dog island where
you've got the dog pub and a number of
nurseries and then coming down to study
here with the sternal junction here the
submitted HTV routing strategy includes
this map which is provided on the screen
it designates the a four three five from
the application site to the south of
studly and a four one eight nine toward
Henle as prohibited HDV routes the red
are designated as advisory HDV routes
the green dots on the plan shows the
location of for automatic number plate
recognition cameras referred to as a NPR
cameras ANPR cameras would also be
located at the entrance to each
individual tenant plot on the reddit
gateway site the ANPR system will be
able to identify where a HTV traveling
to and from redditch gateway has routed
along a HTV prohibited route with a
notification automatically sent from the
camera to the site's travel plan
coordinator SDC will be notified along
with Warwickshire County Council
Highways Department where no reasonable
explanation for a breach is provided to
the travel plan coordinator an example
of reasonable explanation why HTV route
route down a for 3-5 through steadily is
where that HTV is delivering directly to
a premises in Dudley the travel plan
coordinator will report details of all
notifications to the developer site
management company SDC and both
workshare and Worcestershire highway
authorities every three months from
first occupation this slide shows the
location of the application site in red
in the context of both local and
strategic road networks both
Warwickshire and Worcestershire highway
authorities have been consulted on the
discharge of condition application as
has highways England no objection is
raised a steering group comprising
planning and highway officers elected
members
councils and local residents were set up
to facilitate engagement in formulating
the HTV routing strategy and surveys for
steering group meetings have been held
and the applicant has sought to respond
to concerns through amendments to the
strategy chairman the recommendation is
to approve condition 19 HTV routing
strategy and part approved condition 20
methodology for undertaking the HTV
surveys Thank You chairman Thank You
vice and have our first speaker please
which is counselor Steve
Curley
three minutes when you're ready can okay
thank you well I found that something I
didn't know I tell you what I've written
down as I'm concerned because the
management team before the the control
of the cameras the monitoring of the
cameras and the breaches in the HPV
route and all the payments and breaches
are collected by the management the
monies collected are distributed
distributed by the management although
reporting to the council regular of who
they find of how much would it be
possible for them to give map Alberta
green council punch council monthly
figures than for what they are achieving
we feel that the results of the cameras
and the fines are being kept slightly
secret we would also like to be told how
the monies received are being
distributed that effect you from the
fines and if no movies are collected why
we might denote it thank you
yeah sorry yeah we might denote a lot
for the offices well know that that's
worried I'm concerned every all the
money's collected all looking after keys
all done by them not us and we are being
told what they tell us
and I'm sure they've all very honest
people but if they want you to believe
there's no traffic
there'll be no fines we want proof every
month or waivers will have seventy
seventy three months that this is
actually happening
and where's our money going to we're not
going to cease to find where they should
being distributed to the money for the
fires
yep no that's that's very clear offing
now so we'll make sure there'll be a
point for clarification with the offices
that part of the agenda and we'll seek
clarification that less than three
minutes
thank you but yeah thank you very much
but yeah we've got your point you're
concerned about the transparency of the
whole what's happening to and how much
are they going to take
and if you want to be devious about it
if they're in control of everything if
they never give a fine - obviously the
roads are working but we won't know that
boy no that's great thank you very much
thank you for you to go no other
questions
no thank you right three minutes Kenneth
thank you for the opportunity to put the
views of study Parish Council to you and
for granting us three minutes things
improve the first about 30 seconds this
is I think the fourth time I've attended
a meeting for this particular site and
I'm sure not be the last you will have
all seen the comments made by consort
ease and you will also heard from our
offices about the robustness of the
proposed routing strategy we accept that
development needs to go ahead but
Studley and the surrounding parish
councils and the residents we represent
have real concerns about the proposal it
does nothing to protect the villages
around the proposed route such as us
food bank and some born and no
consideration has been given to areas
like cotan and Kings cotton that will
take all of the additional traffic the
proposal does not have any planned
improvements to junctions along the
route many of which are nearing capacity
with the traffic already using them and
no consideration has been given to
providing additional side inch away from
the site to indicate the approve route
the strategy is while the developer
zoned admissions set up to fail because
the only way the cost of administration
operation and monitoring of the routine
such area paid is through the fines that
we live out levied when the drivers
transgress the route table 1 in the
strategy even set it the level of
transgressions being suggested before me
more serious actions taken the
developers our suggestion that based on
the original proposal and traffic date
it with 50 loading bays that 50 HGVs
will go saved so with over three times
that many ways can we anticipate 150 a
day the existing road network
cannot cope with that increase in
traffic surely a strategy that's by its
very nature is set up to fail cannot be
considered robust all that would happen
is after six months when it's proved it
doesn't work the scheme will be closed
and the lawyers will go where they
please
and then the county and District
Council's will have to foot the bill to
put measures in place to negate the
impact that means we would have to pay
for something that should be paid for by
the developer alternatively the
developer would appeal against the
conditions that in our opinion are not
reasonable or appropriate or not
certainly unenforceable because any
enforcement action would have to be
taken by three different councils five
if you can the county councils why would
Bromsgrove put resources into
investigating breaches in sadly a map of
our grain there will be benefits of more
employment but the majority of those
employed at this site will come from
outside Sicilian redditch simply not
enough employed people to fill the
vacancies we urge you to reject the
proposed route in strategy demand a more
robust traffic survey based on current
usage proposals and insurers inbuilt
safeguards to prevent the residents of
sublimino grain Thank You council
bigamist spot on any questions carefully
maybe one that should be for the officer
but if we go back to the plan showing
the routes please the the bottom section
of I can see what number that is
four four eight joining four three five
it's always been a bottleneck even with
traffic you know if there's any proposal
to deal with that if I could share you
would have seen in the submission that
came in from the parish counselor some
photographs of that particular Junction
on a typical weekday morning or weekday
afternoon the traffic tells about two or
three hundred yards the the highways
authority have admitted that that
junction is approaching capacity and to
be fair then venoms has said
yeah there is work against the beams of
it yeah well thank you for that that's
very free informative and well we've got
the highlights officer here as well we
can ask their view but you've given your
anecdotal of you so thank you for that
right any other questions thank you very
much thank you thank you right our next
speaker
our next trio of speakers I believe then
courtly John kitchens and Maureen berry
you've got a minute yeah yep that's fine
so feel free if you just identify who
you are and you've got a minute and far
away when you're ready please I'm Lynn
quarry representing we know it's green
residents Association Council as you've
heard of those some of the waters for
this routine strategy and I'm going to
give you some more now it's supposed to
protect methyl but agreed it it allows
ATVs to circumvent the ARPA cameras by
traveling along hail a map Alberta green
around the dog Ireland the heart of map
Alberta green and also local residents
residential roads in windowed screen it
also allows another rat run through
Sanborn by allowing HGVs to avoid the
inevitable queues it's bernal at the a
435 by turning earlier at the Jubilee in
on the a for for eight officers contend
that HTV drivers will not use these
roads as rat runs because of the
difficult of difficult bends and narrow
roads the routing strategy expects the
HGVs to complete a very much more
difficult turn basically a u-turn at
crabs cross island in Redditch this
junction of the a four four one and four
four eight finally to meet gdpr
requirements we are told that it will
take between 24 to 48 hours before the
breach will be notified to the early
gateway occupy
thank you very much just now get along
the time he was slightly over but I gave
you chance to get off right come have
our next speaker please catch the Barnes
the school is something that I've seen
Maureen berry would prefer to answer
that mr. Cory you're free to go all
right
okay thank you very much all right
coming up the next one please
mr. Gittens again you've got one minute
mr. Gittens it just go very quickly so
if you can be a six inch as possible
good press the red button in the middle
that time thank you very much I'm John
Gatins representing cotan Parish Council
and Kings coat and an object this
application for the following reasons
the routing strategy failed to
acknowledge the eight 435 Southwest burn
lash because it was outside the air
quality zone a sensible approach would
have been to include it in the air
quality zone rather than excluded from
the study area there's ample evidence to
show that residents and schoolchildren
always suffer continuous noise and air
pollution from diesel lorries secondly
vehicles of every description will soon
discover a different route along the
narrow lane to Sanborn to sighs a few
minutes off their journey it is our duty
to draw your attention to a likely chaos
that will occur and finally is it right
that a planning application from an
aimless applicant is considered when
unnamed comments from the public will be
ruled out how can traffic engineers make
accurate predictions will the public and
elected members make a realistic
judgement and kept in the dark ever the
possible implications but it is prudent
to wait until the full facts alone
any questions for mr. Hitchens now I've
taken on your point about air quality
I'll be writing that later thank you
thank you and our final speaker I
believe is Maureen berry again you got a
minute
as possible my name's Maureen berry I
represent a borough Green primary school
Stratford planning committee originally
requested a routing plan at the outset
due to the concerns regarding the
adverse effects on the local residents
in the close proximity of the Gateway
and the associated traffic this problem
is now being assassinated by the
proposal of an unknown tenant to change
various units on into a 8.4 acre
building on the northern site increasing
the docking base from 45 to a potential
250 docking and parking bays an even
greater concern than the original
outline planning to map a borough and
also also it's contradicting to the
Stratford's intention of becoming carbon
neutral by 2030 inevitable breaches of
the proposed routine my drivers should
be enforced through planning conditions
and planning law but when inquiring of
the Stratford district it was made clear
to me that enforcement officers have
breaches that have it never a priority
classification of the breaches and
traffic does not enter into them it
would concern me therefore how many
incidents would occur before any action
would be taken
okay thank you I'm spot on I'll give you
a little no say-so catch the bonds and
we've got Christian Christian
[Music]
calm please we've got as far as they
have proposed that there will be two
crossings they went I believe is Yunho
it's marvelous having said that we have
had two we have had two fatalities so in
a large in two weeks macabre but yes
they proposed that I think it was the
28th of June all comments had to be put
in by so hopefully when I have rallied
the school its instead of objections to
put in total for the crossing so
hopefully there will happen but I don't
know in any further questions right
thank you for free to go thank you very
much
cui up our next speaker which is
gerasole please
right I can recognize gerasole but I
don't know the gentleman next year can
you give me your name please and tell me
what your role this place
I'm Antipas more from B WB consulting
and I produced the HTV routing strategy
alongside Vincent
Faro you've got six minutes thank you
I'm the planning director for Stafford
the applicant and I'm a commentator as
Andy has explained by Andy paths more
who prepared the routing strategy and
he's here to answer technical points of
clarification or technical questions
albeit I am sure that Benson the
county's highway officer will be able to
assist members also members will recall
earlier this year the amendments to the
outline planning application at Redditch
gateway that were approved by this
committee and also members at Bromsgrove
and Redditch the site as we know
benefits from an outline planning
permission for employment uses within b1
b2 and b8 use class 2 of the planning
conditions on the decision notice relate
to the control of HCV traffic these
conditions respond to the previously
raised concerns and they are a means of
addressing these concerns and the
steering group was therefore formed as
applicants Stowe furred and our
transport consultant have met have met
with the steering group on four
occasions since last July officers have
also attended from both the district and
the County Council the HTV routing
strategy before you tonight is a
culmination of the joint work achieved
it has been revised following comments
made at earlier meetings it takes
account of the comments of the steering
group at the last meeting early this
month
further changes were also requested
these included an additional ANPR camera
which now makes four in total we
accepted the requests of the steering
group and we revised the strategy to the
one before you tonight the steering
group was sent a copy of that revised
strategy and the changes are listed on
your office's update sheet the steering
group noted on page 36 of your agenda
three key statements that there be a
fourth AM PR camera which we are
providing the steering group agreed the
nature of the strategy albeit they still
have some reservations about the
Redditch Gateway development but you
will note that this element the
principle of the development is not
before you tonight the steering group
accepted the strategy and they accepted
that there are existing stress points
that it's for the Highways Authority
to keep under review because there are
existing stress points are not resulting
from this development both highways
authorities in Worcestershire and
Warwickshire have been consulted on the
planning application and have raised no
objections to the strategy it's
therefore our position that the strategy
represents a document that we have
collaborated on and produced
collectively with the support of
officers to whom we are grateful for
their time and he did also the members
of the steering group thank you that was
quite exciting and within time which is
good I wish some cancers it's follow
that example right any questions for the
applicants
now obviously frighten them with that
comment stunned how thing over third
there were some comments by the previous
speakers and regarding concerns about
the rat runs if you have that concerns
raised with you and
what comments would you have on now with
your permission chair I think it's a
technical point that I think would
perhaps best be addressed by mr.
Passmore I'll just ask him to answer
that yes the the level of HCV movements
were predicted in the transport
assessment in work undertaken by Walker
County Council routing in that direction
were no more than 8 H TVs per hour as a
maximum the the HTV routing strategy
obviously has been taken on board and
hopefully will be implemented to
alleviate concerns but the actual impact
capacity impact of those H TVs is
considered to be negligible the rat
running side of things the the ANPR
cameras have been identified so that
they pick up the main routes into the
into into the Redditch gateway and it's
not anticipated that the HTV drivers
will go to such lengths to avoid them
for the for the sake of what would
effectively be longer journey times
thank you for the school crossing you
know it's obviously due to you
themselves and the lady speak freely
they don't many years ago I went to
religion it was brought up and they said
oh it seemed more acute
yeah I think we'll leave that one to the
county can't cancel everything else it's
gonna be complete but will me bumper if
we can't stick to questions rather than
statements i did make that point earlier
cats acquittal I'm sure you've got a six
six in question for me haven't you
nor for the applicant in the event that
the m-40 is blocked going east what does
your traffic modeling show is the route
that HTV would use if they wish to
access Stratford or Warwick and is there
a risk there for that if they are unable
to use the road through Hanlon Arden
from Dog Island they will be forced
therefore to go past king of Courtin in
the h-e-b routing strategy one of the
acceptable breaches will be if there are
routes in the vicinity of the sites that
are blocked for whatever reason closed
because of accident or or for other
reasons
however those those routes will need to
be assessed by the travel coordinator
and if the reason is not considered to
be justified then that will be noted and
a breach will still occur all
notifications will be provided to all
the authorities every three months with
the reasons for them being identified as
a breach or if it's deemed to be an
acceptable rerouting so the the
principle of this being transparent is
is is set right from the start didn't
quite answer my question which was will
the existence of an ANPR on the
the Henley Road force vehicles
legitimately to go downs Qing Court and
whereas previously might have gone down
from the dog learn roundabout because
there's an ANPR ANPR one is obviously at
the bottom to the south are steadily
ANPR 3 is on the route to the a4 189 so
if they were forced to route anywhere on
that probative HTV route they would be
picked up and then they would go through
the process through the management
process the model say if they do not go
down I can ask you trenches a four one
eight nine yes because they see signs
saying you can't go down that what
volume would you expect to see going
down through Kings Court as previously
advised we're looking at less than 10 H
TVs per hour as a maximum and the number
of HGVs on the a4 35 at the moment is
around 1200 H TVs a day it's quick
appeared to be some concerns around air
quality around the route that was
proposed
how has your scheme attempted to
mitigate these within certain areas that
were drawn up with concerns so I can you
repeat the question the the air quality
management area that the routing
strategy aims to avoid avoid ATVs
routing through is the study as this
steadily air quality management area
that's that being the basis of the of
the routine strategy sorry I think it
must mean in relation to a comment by
one of the speakers in how that was
associated with that area and if that
area had been considered to extend up to
the route that that area is the air
quality management
right now cancer field in just caught me
going on from what councillor kettle was
saying about the m-40 42 and it is I
can't remember can you go back to that
the color scheme again please they would
turn down v4 2 3 well then are they
allowed to go north up the 441 yes so
the where would that take them out so in
terms of where the approved routes are
identified so that the majority of HGVs
are expected to route on the a4 35 north
to to Junction 3 and the a four-for-one
will allow them to get to Junction 2
there is also the ability to get through
to the n6 directly in in in that in that
routing it's anticipate m5 sorry the m5
as it says on the on the plan
the it's anticipated in the the the
study undertaken by Atkins on behalf of
of warsha County Council the the the HTV
routing study for the a for 35 clearly
demonstrates that over 85 90 % of HGVs
currently routing by the Coventry
highway route from the m42 Junction 3
that that's the the the majority of our
H TVs associated with these developments
are expected to to use that route but
obviously as you've you've identified
there are alternative a route a roads
which follow the the HTV routes
identified by Walsh County Council and
was to show County Council that being
the case surely if
most of people most a lot HGVs getting
sus are aiming for the m5 why can't they
go north to the m5 Bromsgrove because I
think there's quite a good dual
carriageway along a lot of that route
which therefore would do away with a lot
of the game through Kings curtain and
that very narrow section all the way
down to Ulster we anticipate that the
majority will do that but due to the
fact that they are identified HTV routes
at the moment the a four-for-one the a
four four eight or identified hgv routes
and the purpose of the HTV routing
strategies to avoid HGVs rooting through
studly and mapable green the the
Advisory HTV routes were agreed with
both our authorities has been the most
appropriate routes to distribute HTTP
from the development I think you're free
to go thank you very much and come out
the first of our Ward members which is
councillor hunter Seraphin place cancer
didn't want to go first he wants to go
if you're happy to arm-wrestle eight -
who wants to go first it can be
broadcast over Kevin thank you very much
thank you - mr. Chairman I do know that
this development will happen and the
council will eventually approve the
discharge of a routing strategy I'm not
here to ask you to refuse the discharge
merely defer and reconsider it once the
underpinning traffic data is reflective
of what is now known to be developed
there and the
would like you to what will also happen
to the southern site once it does
previously s deceive seemed to be the
only council involved to gave the
Gateway proper proposal proper and due
consideration choosing to insist on a
steering group and deferring a decision
until all the facts and information was
properly established a development with
over a hundred hgv parking spaces is not
the same as a mix of units of differing
classes modeling done on an 8:00 a.m. to
6:00 p.m. basis is not the same as a
24/7 operation technical box ticking and
modeling may suggest that it is but
common sense really does not regarding
the roads there is no help coming if or
when this goes wrong the bomb will not
cover the cost of fixing anything major
and any mrn money is years away if
indeed we can secure any for ourselves
in the first place if you misjudge this
the suffering of residents and commuters
could be long and painful at the moment
this routing strategy is not fit for
purpose based on what is actually going
to happen this is not just my view but
the residents who live in the affected
areas to please notice and consider how
many of the steering group are actually
registered to speak here this evening a
steering group whose terms of reference
were so limiting that they feel that
this is their best and possibly last
chance to have their voice heard
I ask you to help put our residents
minds at ease and that we as a council
of once again properly considered what
two 24/7 warehouses with hundreds of HGV
movements will look like and that the
routing strategy is then fit for purpose
based on that information
having just declared a climate emergency
at the idling engines two roads already
nearing capacity would be remiss and
careless we were all in agreement that
declaring such an emergency would mean
that we must make difficult decisions
and think about things in a different
way I urge you to request at the Acura
information that you need to
future-proof your decision and protect
our residents is made available now
we're aware of what at least one of the
sites is going to be useful in summary I
ask you to please consider deferring
this discharge so your opinions and
decisions can continue to be underpinned
with exact technical data and grounded
in the common sense you've become
synonymous we're showing
any questions just cut on if you start
with a blank sheet of paper what would
you say as no knows from what you got
here but no knows in particular compared
to my reward is that junction of the a
435 and 84 for 8 is impossible I believe
that we were told that they it was
around 85% capacity which is agreeable
to add more traffic to so that's at the
southern point of the the lines that you
can see there yeah thank you
but as we've already heard councillor
Beeman say the traffic queues were
already long HTTPS turning Reuter to
that are going to be particularly
problematic I would suggest so are you
suggesting that there should be no
access down the a 435 I don't have a
proper suggestion to answer that
question with I'm afraid I just think
that as a layman and my residents
talking that that's going to be
impossible I just asked a question
just going back onto that over the a
4:35 obviously
your information of one of the times and
dates of information is it or all day 24
hour a day or what does it vary because
obviously we need to fail to quantify
some of these statements obviously the
officers have all the information to
hand but as far as I'm aware the routine
was 8 a.m. to 6 p.m.
right
any further questions right you're free
to go counter it sorry cancer honey sure
Sara hood you've got five minutes
far away already okay Thank You chair
as a reward member this development is
in no ward of I wasn't original they
have only been here since May a second
so things have moved on since then I'm a
very practical man and I've looked at
this long and hard
okay being a very practical man I've
looked at this and you can have all your
statistics and all your theories and
this route is not actually fit for
purpose it's for what originally was
planned was of small units now we've got
a massive whereas with lots of lorries
and estimates as I've the must have
estimates in my time you can say less
than 10 lorries really you don't know I
am concerned about residents and that's
what my job is as a councillor to
represent my residents I've listened to
many residents and I just don't see that
this is totally unfit for purposes
routes I think it's going to cause too
much even the pollution levels on the
spoon or Junction that's already
Amba without adding to anymore and also
going through cotan the increased
traffic we're already over capacity on
traffic I don't think anybody knows how
many good vehicles come through study
and go down that road you're talking of
a lot of vehicles and this is only going
to increase it okay and can I say this
if I was sitting on my chair I can say
can I have it vote against this proposal
okay your reasons for voting against it
are because see you saying because of
their quality and the junction been well
according to Warwickshire County Council
there is no road improvements for a
number of years I'm alright points of
clarification okay just just so flesh
out what you were saying if you had been
on the committee you would have objected
because of x y&z and voted against it
because it be over capacity as you know
we've gone past the planning stage of
the development but it's changed from
small units at large which totally
changed the whole situation of the road
capacity catch the bonds just occation
was for the offices right you're free to
go and will move seamlessly on two
points of clarification
we're not missed anybody else Oh table
right no no good right he wants to start
with the clarification of ours okay so
plus highways
yeah we'll bend the highway is Alice for
the most appropriate person to answer
your question I go back to the question
I raised earlier on about the junction
egg it's called spur no one at the
bottom there it is a bottleneck par
excellence is there any idea of putting
in a roundabout or traffic lights or
some sort of filtering to help the
traffic there counselor when the
application was fully assessed both
sides the the applicants undertook
modeling which demonstrated that
Junction operated with sufficient
capacity while she county council
undertook its own independent modeling
to reassess the application proposals on
a worst case which showed that Junction
operated within its operational limits
at present there's no imposed
improvements at that location the County
Council is working with Worcestershire
County Council on the major routes
network to try and secure money from the
Department for Transport but as a
competitive bidding process at the
moment there's no proposed improvements
at that location I should point out it
isn't a road it is a double for late and
lobbies do utilize it already so our
present no there's no proposal to
include it okay thank you for that Ben
it was just around the size of the
development and how that's changed over
time as far as the outline goes and not
so how abouts been then considered by
highways over the course of the plan so
from a planning side this plan shows the
approved parameters plan which was
approved through the section 73
application so prior to this there was
another parameters plan which was
approved that approved for a master's
plan included the retention of the black
soil was Brooke here but in terms of
anything else
there wasn't any change to the mix of
uses there wasn't any change to maximum
building heights or anything like that
so from the original outline to the
section 73 the only changes related to
rejigging the employment zones because
there was a potential occupier who
needed a larger footprint than could be
contained within the original outline
parameters plan that's the sort of
planning side and then then can advise
on how the implications of that in terms
of highway modeling so I've just I'd to
say to all members that this application
has been completed by three highway
authorities so it's been considered by
washer worcestershire and highways
England Bromsgrove District Council also
point to their own transport consultants
Mott MacDonald to do an independent
review of all the work be debated on
half the applicants but also all the
responses from the highway authorities
so it's been a robust assessment the
impacts through the April 35 are
negligible in accordance with what we
were required to do in the national
planning policy framework so therefore
we couldn't reassess it under the
section 73 we did tend to take a further
review both Walker was tissue and
highways England but actually it will do
saw a slight reduction in the trip
generate traffic generation for the
development site and that's based on the
outline proposal so there's no
justification on what on what on what
grounds we could refuse the application
on highway grants just a quick follow on
format I think I've got a reasonable
idea but there seems to be some doubt in
the room over what type of modeling is
carried out to assess these could you
just clarify so modeling has been
undertaken has been strategic transport
modeling using pastiches strategic
transport model for Bromsgrove and
redditch and in addition we watcher and
and the applicants also undertook
modeling using what you can to counsel
stood leaper AMEX model which is a
specific model that we have for Studley
and the 8th or 3/4 corridor and that was
undertaken as well so we've done that
and then performed that we do Junction
impact assessments where we look at
junctions in isolation as well so it's a
very detailed assessment that we have to
undertake as a Highway Authority and as
I said it's demonstrated at the network
within stood lead operating within
operational capacity as a highway
authority that we have been concerned
about the air quality impact
of additional HGVs through Studley and
it being an AQ ma and that's the legal
that's the legal tool that we are using
to implement the h GV routing strategy
the a thief if I could go on chair don't
mind but the eighth the eighth or 3/5
corridor is a strategic corridor for the
county but it's also fundamental for the
national road but a strategic road
network nationally when there have been
issues on the m5 or the m42 it is a
diversionary that we must maintain
operational for highways England so you
may have noted there were roadworks on
the m5 to put in smart phone smart
motorways on the diversion which was the
a 4:35 but it was incorrectly signed and
we had to step into that wave height was
england to divert them up the a46
instead so there is measures that we
actively do that but it is a diversion
boot and it is heavily utilized by
therefore by h tvs i but we have to
maintain it at all times right
what do you mind and I'll come back to
you then John about the air quality and
I know the warden member took bernal
Junction level of quality
what other assessments were done about
air quality please from memory a full
air quality assessment was undertaken in
relation to the outline that is covered
by the outline matters though so it's
something which I'm not really in a
position to comment on today because
that's already being granted
in as much as the air quality management
area is key here that's because it
provided us justification to require the
HDB routing strategy and so that in
itself is considered to help to mitigate
any impact from redditch gateway on the
aqm a
just feeling I understand the need to
keep emergency routes if the m42 is
blocked for some reason but I would have
my feelings are strong I think from
driving in and around reddish and bronze
Grove there are are some very good
highways or roads in that area and
therefore has any modeling being done to
see what about moving it that way rather
than coming south through neuron
steadily I should haste about that this
isn't removing all haze TVs from Studley
this only relates to hgv movements
related to this development it's not all
hate TVs because we can't control the
others in terms of reddish gateway we
have done a proactive review of the
routes and you're quite right counselor
there asks some good routes through
reddit which are capable the a48 towards
Blom's grove linking up with the 838 is
a good loot the a four-for-one linking
up to the m42 junction - and also you
have the a 435 northbound which is only
three miles to m42 junction totally so
we believe that most the roots are there
in terms of the April 4 1 and a 4 4 8
they are both classified a roads and
therefore they can take HGV traffic and
they do at present and both Warwickshire
and Worcestershire are satisfied that
they can accommodate those movements I
understand that residents are concerned
that people are going to start using
country lanes but having driven them
over the last couple of weeks myself on
my way in and out of work I can't see
how a HTV would find them suitable for
themselves but we as a county council we
will proactively take them and continue
to take them into review along so I wish
account to Council in this area
then two points one one of these
speakers from the parishes right the
beginning spoke about concern about the
collection of fines from people using
the NPR and what is allowed and what is
not allowed and then I think when the
applicant spoke they have the discretion
to determine when there is a a reason to
breach the traffic regulations can if
the applicant was to give us a free rein
to any any lawyer going through anywhere
at any point in time does the Highway
Authority have an ability to reinstate
penalties in the event that the
management company was rather too
relaxed about it if I can just start and
I'll hand over to Alice because Alice
understands the enforcement aside from
Stratford district counsel better than I
do but what your County Council will be
notified of those breaches and we will
expect to be seeing the fines and we
want to see that evidence on the three
monthly or monthly whatever it is
reports as I stated in the condition if
we've believed that fines or routing
isn't being implemented we will then
talk to drop the district council about
taking enforcement action also within
the section 106 that was agreed for the
site there's a two hundred thousand
pound bond sitting there and if both
Worcestershire and Warwickshire feel
that the HGV routing strategy isn't
being implemented correctly or isn't
being implemented at all or we can't get
the applicants to change the HTV routing
strategy because something will observed
we will draw down that two hundred
thousand pound bond to turn to take
measures to prevent them so there is a
bit of a it was a bit of a stick to beat
them with I should use our phrase but
there is in terms of the funds that they
cite are going to be collecting I have
turned over to Alice in terms of that
yeah I think there was a couple of
points made with regards to the fining
and that's essentially a private matter
in as much as it's the developer trying
to make sure that future tenants of the
site do comply with the routing strategy
as far as SDC is concerned that's a
separate matter is for us to decide
through our enforcement team and through
investigation of any breaches as to
whether
enforcement action is appropriate so
defining isn't directly related to
planning albeit it is detailed in the
breeding strategy as a private matter a
private enforcement matter if you like
so there's a couple of things
paragraph 5.4 of the routing strategy
confirms that the estate management
charge further edits Gateway development
will include the cost of operating and
managing the ANPR monitoring system so
that's just to assure us that there is
the funds there to make sure that this
does actually happen and then secondly
in terms of refining paragraph 5.21 any
funds collected from private finding
will be used to offset the estate
management charge for those tenants
complying with the HDB route strategy
and again stressing that it is separate
to the public enforcement which SDC may
choose to do Stafford is the applicant
are proposing that they basically can
change that management charge depending
on how tenants are are or are not
breaching the routing strategy so it's
just an extra tool in their tool kit to
ensure that it is complied with so
repeat offenders do have to pay a higher
management charge now that money goes
back into ensuring a constant management
and maintenance of the ANPR system so
that money doesn't come anywhere near us
as it shouldn't do it sir private matter
and then it's for our SCC enforcement
team to look at any breaches which are
reported to us or which come in as a
result of the HTV surveys to decide
whether there's planning hard to justify
serving any sort of breach of condition
notice thank you I think the last
sentence was the important one as far as
I'm concerned if Laurie's if the
management company decided in the
interest their tenants that they're not
going to take a hard but very soft
enforcement policy does the District
Council have the ability to enforce
a strict usage of the non usage of the
only route if SDC enforcement consider
there to be planning harm that arrives
as a result of any sort of breach then
as with any breach of planning condition
it's within their remit to decide to
take formal enforcement actions so
that's where again it's kind of
irrelevant what the developer is
choosing to do from a private
enforcement side the focus for us is
that this strategy does still enable us
to enforce at any point that we see fit
and just to sort of hopefully reassure
members our enforcement team was
involved in checking through this HTV
reaching strategy to make sure that it
didn't prejudice their ability to be
able to enforce from an SDC side so
hopefully that should give some sort of
reassurance that if if required we will
take the necessary enforcement action so
just for some clarity who's managing the
in at the ANPR system so the site
management company would manage it
loosing themselves yes exactly but
there's a requirement to provide us with
the surveys to show the breaches every
three months in accordance with the HTV
routing strategy and what who determines
the level of fines I mean if it's 20 P
ago it's not a great deterrent if it's
16 16 Quinton points on your license and
that's considerably more 5.25 point to
one of the routing strategy states that
in keeping with existing legal penalties
for contravening a weight restriction
order the redditch gateway financial
penalty will be set to a maximum of 1000
pounds per Bridge but I must come back
to the original point that that is a
private matter the defining of how
Stoffer decide to operate the HTV
routing strategy is not a planning
matter that we can have any say in
gee sure if I may just just reiterate
what I think I've heard Alice say which
is that we have a perfectly adequate
enforcement system that we can operate
in order to to ensure that this routing
is abided by in addition to a perfectly
adequate enforcement system we have a
private enforcement system that the
operator has undertaken to operate so it
shouldn't be seen that we're testing the
private system to see whether it's good
enough the public wants good enough on
top of which we've got another one
that's that's what officers are trying
to communicate members thank you just
quit welcome for Ben I know that
junction with the 435 and the 448 as
counsel Felix said it's not a terribly
healthy one we've got to rotate south
we've got the four four one and the four
three five was there any consideration
that the fourth or one game throughout
would Bank could be a preferred route
rather than allowing vehicles to cross
over to the 435 and if it wasn't why
wasn't the a four four one is in the
control of Worcestershire County Council
the a 4 4 a 4 3 5 is why sure both
routes are identified as being suitable
we can't for force at the third route
before mode uses you know everyone pays
their vehicle tax whether your car or
your big lorry you're in able to go
anywhere you like on our public road
network but we made sure that both loops
are clearly identified so drivers can't
and can utilize them both unfortunately
there's not notes no reason why can
control that to be a preferred route
would there be any funding or what is an
opportunity to improve that Junction the
4 for 8 for 35 as I said before the
County Council is working with
Worcestershire counts Council on the
major routes network
is a bidding process for funding with
the department on sport we will submit
bids as we always do and we are very
successful as a County Council but we
will be have to be reviewed by DFT who
will make the final decision I think
we've turned that quite well and just
one more clarified a bit about heisting
than they've looked at this and they
were happy with the routes suggested so
highways England have looked at it from
the perspective that they manage the a46
to the south and the m42 they are
satisfied there's no impact on their
road networks but that's it but what's
the issue and why you're satisfied
they're the most appropriate route to
get to those networks very that's one
sign inch that's one of my book bears
and I noticed you mentioned that when
there was the smart way to ion the m5
was it was the m-40 that going among
which one
there was incorrect scientists so you've
got to change it and put on the eye 46
can we ensure that any signage that's
put up is appropriate and effective
that was just my request thing so the
signage is currently being reviewed at
the access Arrangements as it goes
through technical approval and we've
provided special signage which indicates
indicates to hate Givi drivers their
routes that they should be taking from
the site access there's any chance you
can make it foolproof entire best none
right so we've a lot of discussion we've
had a lot of information from the ward
members the applicants and the objectors
shall we gone through the bite who wants
to start on this one because I went to
village with hazel rice councillor hazel
right when he first started really and
they all the applications in Stratford
and Reddy's young Bronzeville
and there we've come down to our n if
you
put it that way I'm very pleased that
the cross name is going in I didn't ask
the applicant when it was going in how
much he was going to be putting as far
as I'm concerned the steering group has
worked with it there are obviously a lot
of problems on the road but there is on
my road I've got a new sign it's gone up
no HGV on the other Road it's joke as
you might I thought was an April Fool
our concern is all the work has been
done our support the officers
recommendation mr. Mill's
yeah thanks mr. Jim yes I quite agree is
that a proposal Casavant thanks mr.
Jimmy yeah there does seem to be a lot
of work being put into this and we had
so many assessments and different people
are going to working on this scheme so I
will support this recommendation that we
approve condition 19 for the HGB routing
strategy mr. chairman you happy to
second I am indeed cancer careful and I
think whenever you see a major HTV
scheme it causes significant concern and
worry and distress but as Mr said did
point out that if a vehicle has a
licensee can use the public road
one hopes that this scheme will do its
best to mitigate this development the
developers been approved it would be
very nice to turn around so we don't
want it but I don't think you know we
have an economic development which we've
approved vehicles have to get in and get
out as long as for instance in the
immediate vicinity are protected and I
believe that the yellow bit has
identified its doing that I do have a
problem with the a four four two four
four eight four three five Junction but
mr. sim has pointed out that the what I
think he said has been an application
for funding from the government to see
about road improvements was that correct
then we're currently working on the bits
they haven't been submitted with working
on the bids so bids are being put in to
try and improve that it would have been
nice to see that coming out of section
106 monies but I'm sure mr. natural told
me we can't do that as long as which
kind of counselors working trucks on
make that improvement right we've
proposed it and a second transfer
Dominus you want to have something
briefly I'm just concerned that the
signs of hgv didn't say can't danger
Council of bonds but no my basic thing
is that I would like to see more signage
encouraging people to get around the
four-for-one rather than go around while
studly and the supernal thing but apart
from that we're stuck and so therefore
I'll go along with it
right person a second long so I'm
happier that there is the bond that if
the rat runs are going to appear we can
potentially put some measures in to
prevent lemon mr. Simms mentioned that
so that's that sort of slightly
alleviated my fear so should we go to
vote on this proposed in a second the
planning manager is to approve condition
19 Heights TV route and survey and part
approve condition 20 H TV surveys of
hybrid Commission 1980 37 46 very so all
those in favor
unanimous chair the committee resolves
to approve condition 19 and part three
condition 20 of the hard way permission
18 / 0 37 46
bear with me I'm just need to check
something before we start to the next
check some think it's button to one the
application so you just bear with me you
can come back in to MIT
we'll move on our next item is 19 / 0 0
semaphore I / fu our 68 Tom's turn line
studly before we move onwards 1 a class
catch the beam and to come forward the
table piece so I believe you're the
drawing your objection yes Jeff I am I
am a great believer in an offense or
objects to something they should attend
that meeting and speak on that objection
we didn't register for me to speak so
therefore I have no issues with this
going straight to a delegated decision
thank you all the objection yeah and you
can leave the type of that thank you
and as the ward member who also objected
I believe is not here as well
and not registered speak I'm asking
committee to give me approval to
delegate this to officers all those in
favor just relates the officers report
you refer to main rural centers
requiring 3,800 houses the stubbly is
specifically identified as a main rural
center and has a core strategy
allocation of a hundred of which 83 have
been approved plus 60 I think we're in
the pipeline I'm not I just slightly
concerned but when we have very specific
information in the core strategy we are
looking at a general category wrong than
a specific category I just wanted to
make that point other than that I'm
quite happy to pretty good elliegator
differential
if we're going to through a council
process we should go through the normal
process and ask the applicant to come
forward to actually put these cakes and
then the officers should so thank your
thing on we plugged in whether that was
just a statement or you actually asking
a question no it's just a statement -
we'll do that one night well can we make
a statement and say any other business
chair instead of this application
because then if we're going to start
discussing versus they need to go
through the proper process and start to
finish
yeah I'm not I'm not happy that I think
this is a question council cattle wants
to put to the officers statement I don't
know a social response from officers
okay I'm happy for it to be delegated
and would support the proposal and any
questions regarding this general points
on the five-year house and land supply
in major all centers will be done
outside of this correct thank you right
so we've had a proposal
to delegate this decision to officers
all those in favor
unanimous chair committee resulted the
gate application 9000 said make five
slash if you are two offices thank you
very much
all right the next application is 19/2
zero zero eight six zero six eight slash
ful chop or gate large Chapel Lane Allen
Hall and I think we've got the same
situation as before this is here because
of the Parish Council objection the
parish camp sort of not registered to
speak against agenda which the speaker
and neither is the ward member so again
if we're happy to delegate this to
offices decision
we do registers pictures yeah I'm so
obviously he didn't register speak until
I'm any Michael so that's quite
microphone on please
I'll second that
so we're going to vote from that all
those in favor tooth decay this decision
to officers chair to yourselves to
dedicate application nineteen / 0 0 806
if you are taught says thank you right
will move on yet we'll move on to our
last item on the agenda which I will
stand down and that kept for those chair
thank you
right good evening we've now come to the
last item on the agenda which is
application number 19
zero one one one six leek ful the barn
wind Mill Hill Farm renewal lane chest
and lemon spa this is to hear the
hearing on the ground floor kitchen
extension to the rear so it's over to
you thank you thanks Jeff this is an
application for a single-story rear
extension the application site is part
of a complex of barns at Wimmer hill
farm outside of Chesterton the site is
identified here by the black dot here
the red line indicates the applicants
land ownership the green line indicates
a footpath to the north of the site lies
a scheduled ancient monument which is an
ancient Roman settlement these images
show the layout of the wider site of
particular significance is the linear
layout of the brown conversions which
can be seen on the left-hand side of the
courtyard you can see that the buildings
are all in line with no noticeable
offshoots here are the elevations of the
existing building as you can see on the
left of the property in the existing
West elevation the property has already
been extended which was approved in 2004
this can be seen also on the ground
floor plan here are the proposed
elevations as you can see a single-story
extension is proposed with a pitched
roof it will be perpendicular to the
existing building and here on the ground
floor plan this photograph shows the
location of the proposed extension and
this one shows to the right-hand side of
the building including the neighbors
showing the extension would be the only
offshoot of the linear form to conclude
we recommend refusal of this application
due to it being contrary to part G of
the development requirements SPD which
cites the extensions to ban conversions
are not acceptable as well as the
district design guide which says the
same and extending your home
the proposal causes significant harm to
the character and built form of the barn
and the rural character of the wider
area setting a poor precedent for other
bond conversions thanks Joe right I
think we have our first speaker which is
mr. Andy Turner from Chester and
Kingston parish council supporting
application Thank You chair thank you
for inviting me to make my
representation you'll see in my report
that I fully support this development
for a number of reasons but I'd also and
I don't nobody goes in my three minutes
I just wanted to point out in the
appendix item 8 appendix 1 this is a
wholly inaccurate representation of the
site the buildings are labeled
incorrectly the names of the houses are
incorrect and any councillor wishing to
get a perception of the true nature of
this area he
doesn't do credit that names houses are
named wrongly houses are in the wrong
location and I would ask councillors to
ignore item 8 appendix 1 because it is
not representative and it's very
disappointing that this should be in the
pack in the parish of jettison that I
represent there have been several
extensions ok can you just sit back from
the mic so in the part of Chesterton
since the core strategy and the SPD
there have been several extensions to
properties in the parish they have been
perpendicular they have been to barns
and there are several instances I can
give precise examples of this at
honeysuckle cottage last year two-story
extension with perpendicular relief
Kingston farm barn last year barn
extended with set with considerable
perpendicular construction this
particular application is for a small
house it was a cowshed it is not
historic it was a cowshed from the 20th
century it has been sensitively
developed so far and to counter the
report from the planning officer I would
contend this is a sustainable
development so cs1 is adhered with on
cs9 this is sensitive it is sensitive
developed it does not disturb any public
views or vistas and not harming existing
ones so I would contend that the core
strategy policies are upheld and what is
more when it comes down to the
neighborhood amenity comment which
states quote you had 30 seconds yeah
that this development is not of a size
that would cause any material harm to
living conditions of neighboring
residents by way of loss of light loss
of Outlook loss of privacy or over
bitter impact it is a very small 4 meter
by 3 meter development it is less than
10% of the existing area of the property
and it sits alongside the properties
that have floated the planning
regulation that are running businesses
and extending their properties without
permission thank you stay there thank
you any questions for thank you right so
we have next applicant mr. Andrew and
please thank you I'll just speak my wife
as I did at my wedding
Andrew thank you very much for the time
for us to come here I was sort of
reiterate some of the words that Andy
has actually said is a small band
conversion of a semi-detached building
which was a cowshed in the past and it
follows the original conversion and we
were very concerned ourselves about the
state of the area and we wanted to make
sure that we did comply with all the
regulations hence we invested in
employing the local builder using local
materials and the bricks are the same we
also looked and surveyed around all the
other years and Baron conversions and
other barns which are perpendicular to
the building is in line with the
traditional barn conversions in in the
Warwickshire area and I think Andy's
mentioned a couple and if you even
google the the sites you can see quite a
few others that are traditional barns
width perpendicular aspects to it so
we're there the key thing for us we want
to make sure that we enhance our
property and actually the the key
element for that for us was around
privacy and security
I think Andy mentioned the the local
businesses are running from the earth
that we needed to ensure
that we have some privacy and security
with non members of our community coming
in and out of the venue so from our
point of view it's really important that
we actually maintain the style and
aspect of the building understand they
already pointed out it's at least half a
mile through trees to the nearest view
point from that and the conversion isn't
behind the the main building and
wouldn't be seen from any walkway that
passes across to the Roman fort I'm
really pleased that both a local
residents are of all very supportive and
we are very meals to prove that as well
as the parish council or another local
councillor and so I would really support
that process going forward the other
aspect that would we would suppose just
at the end really is a piece of advice
and guidance on the planning process if
that's possible we were asked to 500
pounds an hour Archaeological Survey
which you know if it doesn't count
ravine why do we pay in advance of a
controversion why can we not pay that
after this planning issue and it seems
that we only a lot of money for
something and others without lis the
similar sites and money but that the
other aspect I would like to point out
is that you've already approved as and I
said through going through your minutes
you've already approved the number of
bound conversions in this area and also
we would have not might have been
threatened no I'm really finished
because I don't really we're treating a
lot of and aspyn's and I so thank you
very much any questions for
for the applicant thank you thank you
very much
thank you wait how about how about ward
member we we are honored I think
Athene's must be the first one you've
attended isn't it it is that means it's
a guest appearance it's serious stuff
thank you for hearing my support for
this application I fully support the
comments made by the applicant on the
chair of the parish council I know that
the planner in this case is refusing on
the grounds of Park G of the development
requirements SPD citing extensions will
not normally be acceptable etc note the
word normally which means there is scope
for movement on this by the committee
can I draw your attention to the fact
that these Park G appears to be guidance
only the guide is set within the policy
which is the core strategy the guidance
is not the policy itself and concerned
around the interpretation of the guide
in that it may be confused as policy
which in fact I believe it is not can I
draw your attention to the fact that
other planning committees around the
country including recent previous
Stratford district council planning
committees have granted small extensions
on barns like this and properties of
this kind evidenced by the speakers that
we've just gone before me you can also
look at our own council minutes
successful appeals by other similar
applicants and they can be brought
forward if required there appears to be
inconsistency in how different planners
in this council interpret this guide
it's also clear committees interpret the
information in a different way and do
grant permission regardless of the
policy and guidance I request that the
committee does do a site visit if one
has not been carried out as this does
not harm the community this request
regardless of policy started by the
planners in the core strategy the points
are covered in the core strategy
supports application not refused there
is no evidence to refuse this small
extension qualifies in my mind to be
grown granted it is in a rural setting
yes off the beaten track not open to
view a setting and it's still in keeping
with the area or the neighbors support
it and it will not cause any issue from
anyone in any way if you visit the site
you will see that it does not impact in
any way whatsoever or cause any
significant material harm to media or
the wider area in fact it enhances it
especially when there's unregulated
breeze block buildings across the road
from it which is now subject to
investigation by this council makes this
claim flawed it does in fact meet cs1
cs9 cs20 si si si si it relates to the
cultural assets and I do not see how a
round a bill to breeze block on the
unregulated building is a historic or
cultural value and how this would
detract from the area and it does meet
the standard set by this council I
believe this is a proper see in action
the SPD offers flexibility now ask this
committee to show its strength and also
be flexible and grant accordingly as we
have outlined evidence can be found in
STC minutes to support the claim that
SDC has previously granted permission
for extensions to barns in our district
I do not understand why it's not being
granted on this occasion and perhaps SDC
need to review it to process and
decision making to a case-by-case basis
not just give a general refusal to all
we are correct this would save time
streamline process reducing cases for
appeal finally can I draw attention back
to the comments from the chair of the
Paris that there is inappropriate
unregulated planning and businesses
ruling in this area residents and not
doing the right thing in the correct
legal way while this applicant is
engaged with everyone including myself
followed the correct processes and
legislation I would favor acknowledging
this fact and that the committee listens
as well as it hears and grants this
application based on the merits and
evidence of this individual case and the
fat previous grants have been made by
Committees of this council before many
thanks for listening and hearing spot on
thank you and any questions for all
councillor
thank you there's one Jackie you
mentioned have been numerous decisions
which contradicts this have you gotten
examples I think the chair cited some of
the examples for me but we have got them
we can either look at Stratford district
council minutes can we stick to the
application Pandavas not compare other
applications thank you we can it's well
evidence in our own Stratford district
council minutes I can't cite them here
and now but we have got on the chair of
the parish has referred to them yeah
thank you thank you thank you
right any any more questions for world
member thank you thank you right just
now points of clarification
and I was following on from Cal
Seattle's point the points made by the
parish council suggested that president
had been made in previous bond
conversions in the area is has that been
checked against when making the
assessment German thank you where to
start with with that answer you have
heard that other extensions have been
allowed in the immediate vicinity and
you have you can see quite clearly from
our report that we're recommending
refusal for this you can rest assured
that your officers are well aware of all
the extensions that have been allowed in
the area and you can rest assured that
we have evaluated this application
against your policies against your
current policies against your SPD that
was adopted towards the end of last year
which might explain why these extensions
are different to extensions that have
been allowed previously because your
policy has changed as we heard from
councilor kettle earlier you know
policies change we make decisions on the
policy or recommendations on the policy
as it stands today so the answer to your
question counselor is yes we are fully
aware of those other extensions and yes
we do stand by our recommendation in
this instance
councillor kettle mr. Barco weather is
extinctions that will prove will they do
bombs or were they too coffee juice
chairman as I've mentioned two members
previously if they want us to give
detailed answers such as that they knew
do need to give us prior information
prior notice so we can check and so we
can advise on the basis of what I heard
it sounded as though some of the
extensions were to cottages which of
course are different D bars but I don't
know because I wasn't please please
thank you
any more questions there are exceptions
outlined within part G of the
development requirements I'm a new
counselor so if you could just explain a
bit of that to mayor be appreciated
thank you for asking that question I'm
going to take a Liberty with the the
wording and change the order of it so I
think it will be crystal clear when I
change the order if you want I'll read
it as written afterwards but I'm going
to change the the order first of all
where necessary to link buildings small
out shots Orlean twos in the traditional
manner may be acceptable
that's my rewording of it where
necessary to link buildings what the
policy what the wording actually says is
small out shots Orlean twos in the
traditional manner may however be
acceptable where necessary to link
buildings so the reason I reordered it
is to make it clear that it's contingent
on it being necessary to link buildings
that's where extensions are acceptable
to barns where it's necessary
linked buildings please do can I add
also that that's a small out shirt or
lean-to which we don't consider that
this is it's a room it's not only in -
it has a pitched roof of its own it
doesn't carry on the eaves of the barn
and it's not a lean-to in any way so we
don't think that there is any way that
you could construe it under that small
art suits and lean-to sort of exception
there please no no you can't make any
more points you cannot make any more
points at the moment clarification at
the moment
councillor house just cook it
um has this been extended before this
part is yes I'll just go back to the
photograph she'll be a bit confused bit
on the left here with the three roof
lights and the large windows this is an
extension which was improved approved in
2004 I believe it has been extended
before no more points of clarification
no
then oh there is mum oh can we go to the
bay now who wants to be kickoff first
yes yes please suit I've got to go with
the officers on this in Thai so we had a
bond that was refused to be extended at
the back and they are therefore had to
build an underground bedroom to extend
the property which I felt was very
dangerous there was another bomb and
that again wanted to be but this was out
in the countryside they wanted to extend
with porches etcetera again the officers
turned it down so as far as I'm
concerned if we approve this then the
other properties that I have in my ward
have every right to go against the
council for change of policy so I have
got to go with the officers in this
instance and I propose to go to proposal
thank you any more councillor kettle I
find this friendly a very difficult one
it's very small it's one application on
quite nicely to building we did adopt
the SPD in December I believe and what
I'm looking for or hope to see was
exceptions why this classifies as an
exception to that policy
and we haven't really got it and the
other thing concerts that is it's a pop
bar the footpath that Long's on the side
of the property it is quite a long way
on waiting for the property what's going
on in relation to other properties there
that may or may not be result of
enforcement action as far as like I said
completely irrelevant to this we nearly
need to look at this actual proposal in
front of us so it's the question is
whether it is so small to be immaterial
or whether it is a matter of principle
and therefore we should decide it in
line with the pub with with the policy
Thank You councillor kettle anybody else
got to me I'm just looking through this
from any of the surrounding bones or no
no objections supporting support there
were no third party letters of support I
believe no the ward member and the
parish council supported and that was
the end representations that we were
saving nothing for many of the people
who live there know nothing from
neighbors or any other party
judges to confirm the Constitution if
the members wish something to be
clarified then they can invite the
member back but she cannot invite
herself back to the table to clarify any
matter sir yeah okay Jackie can you come
back to the table then no Jackie miss
out questions to you
not what you want to say is anybody can
what questions for councillor Harris
please
have any have any neighbors neighbors
rotating or objecting laws no but I've
spoken with them and they are supportive
of this and they have written and spoken
to the applicant and supportive of it
but I haven't got anything in writing
for you but I have spoken and I haven't
had anyone is district man neglect we've
got a clarifier thanks here okay
there's Emily a any questions for
councillor Harris any more questions
thanks thank you Thank You councillor
fielding the ones that were refused the
parish council and I supported
particularly the one in tighter
but again it was refused by the officers
it didn't go to committee there was a
perfectly legitimate scheme to connect
it on to other buildings but again it
was turned
by the officers so I can't see the
difference between this and what has
been refused elsewhere in the district
by the awesome Peugeot proposed free
from you councillor fielding do we have
a seconder three of second and third
councillor fielding do we have your
second in your second then right we have
a proposer and the seconder not looking
very happy there mister so
recommendation is it is to refuse this
by the counts are by the officers do we
get can we have a vote on that please
the officers James Bond so sorry it's by
the committee by the committee I'm so
sorry we have our vote on that to
support the officers recommendation all
those in favor of
for chairman against German abstentions
hmm thank you so this good results to
refuse this recommender through your
application thank you
right thank you for cancer Mills any
urgent business Olivia are you really
sure you know we could stay a bit longer
if you want to know right so I now
declare the meeting closed it 9:05 thank
you